Hey, I'm Josh Radner, and I am joined as ever by my dear friend, Craig Thomas.
嘿，我是乔什·拉德纳，一如既往，我的好朋友克雷格·托马斯也加入了我的节目。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hello, Craig.
你好，克雷格。
It's great to see you again.
很高兴再次见到你。
This is a bonus episode of how we made your mother, and it's something we like to call general questions.
这是《老爸老妈的浪漫史》制作花絮的特别番外篇，我们喜欢把它叫做“常规问题”。
General questions.
常规问题。
So we're joined also by our pal and producer Alec Lev.
所以我们的朋友兼制片人亚历克·莱夫也加入了我们。
Hello Alec.
你好，亚历克。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hello.
你好。
Do you have any general questions for us?
你有什么常规问题要问我们吗？
I am honest, my man.
说实话，兄弟。
Let's do it.
来吧。
All right.
好的。
You missed your salute, Craig.
克雷格，你漏掉你的军礼了。
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
Excellent.
太棒了。
Oh, awful.
哦，糟透了。
Yeah.
是啊。
So I was never in the army.
所以我从来没当过兵。
I never will be in the army.
我以后也绝不会当兵。
Yeah.
是啊。
Hi, guys.
大家好。
This week, people are curious, I would say, in the large about how TV kind of gets made.
本周，人们普遍对电视剧是怎么拍出来的很感兴趣，我想可以说是这样。
There's a lot of questions.
有很多问题。
And by the way, this is about episode three sweet taste of liberty.
顺便说一下，这是关于第三集《自由的甜味》。
These are questions about episode three, right?
这些都是关于第三集的问题，对吧？
It is, that is correct.
是的，没错。
There were a lot of questions about Liberty Bells and licking things, and we're gonna focus more on the production side of things.
有很多关于自由钟和舔东西的问题，但我们将更多地关注制作方面的事情。
I'm just gonna give you a couple examples, but then I'm gonna kind of broaden out the question.
我只举几个例子，然后我会把问题稍微扩展一下。
So, LJ spectrum asks, how far into filming did you create the opening sequence and bar photos?
所以，LJ spectrum问：拍到第几集时，你们才制作了开场镜头和酒吧照片？
Was it specifically for this episode and then turned into the opening montage?
这专门是为这一集拍的，然后才变成了开场剪辑吗？
How did you do that?
你们是怎么做到的？
And then Oscar underscore Cal Vajor says just out of curiosity is this the same basement we see later on at Stella's house.
然后Oscar underscore Cal Vajor说，出于好奇，这和后来在斯特拉家里看到的地下室是同一个吗？
So just thinking about how, yeah, I don't know, but the answer to that or what?
所以就在想，是的，我不知道，但是有这个的答案吗？
I've never actually seen this show.
我其实从没看过这部剧。
I don't have any, I have no answers to any of this.
我对这些完全没有任何答案。
I heard it so, obviously we have viewers who know a lot more than we do.
我听说过，所以很显然，我们的观众比我们知道得要多得多。
But I think what this is going to is just kind How do you make a television show?
但我认为这正说明了一个问题：电视剧到底是怎么拍出来的？
And I think if we can walk through one thing, we'll answer a lot of people's questions.
我想如果我们能经历一件事，就能回答很多人的问题。
And maybe we could do a helium style of, how did Craig see a week of production and how did Josh see a week of production?
也许我们可以用一种交替的方式：克雷格眼中一周的制作是怎样的，而乔什眼中一周的制作又是怎样的？
How was this show made?
这部剧是怎么制作出来的？
Can I go back to a thing?
我能回到刚才的一个问题吗？
Because I actually, I really like the first question about the open credit sequence.
因为我其实，我真的很喜欢关于开场演职员表序列的第一个问题。
Me too.
我也是。
Great, great.
太好了，太好了。
So, and we can get back to this out because I like this too, but Craig, where did the idea for the opening credits This is kind of like friends, pictures, kind of popular.
所以，我们等下可以再回到这个话题，因为我也喜欢这个，但是克雷格，开场字幕的想法是从哪来的？这有点像《老友记》那种照片形式，当时挺受欢迎的。
That was from the beginning.
那是从一开始就有了。
That was when we were writing the pilot, when the pilot got picked up.
那是我们在写试播集时，试播集被预订的时候。
We always had that idea.
我们一直都有那个想法。
This is a weird thing that I don't think I've ever talked about.
这是一件很奇怪的事，我觉得我以前从来没说过。
For a minute, I remember Carter Bay's, I think it might have been his concept to begin with.
有一会儿，我记得卡特·贝斯，我觉得这可能一开始就是他的概念。
And the way he wanted to do it at first was pictures of just young people in New York, not even our cast.
他一开始想用的方式是，只放纽约年轻人的照片，甚至都不是我们的演员。
This very abstracted idea of like, you're just seeing youth in New York.
这种非常抽象的想法，就像是：你只是在看纽约的青春。
It could be anyone.
可以是任何人。
seeing this pastiche of New York City and people out.
看到这种纽约市和人们外出的拼贴画。
And it's just them and their friends, blah, blah, blah.
而且只有他们和他们的朋友，巴拉巴拉。
And I think we gained it out.
我想我们把这个给推演出来了。
We started looking at it, we're like, this is too weird.
我们开始看着它，然后我们想：这太奇怪了。
Who are these people?
这些人是谁？
These aren't the same.
这些演员不对。
I mean, this is in the cast of the show.
我的意思是，这不是剧中的演员。
And that was how we learned.
这就是我们吸取教训的方式。
I mean, it was sort of a little too artsy of an idea, maybe.
我的意思是，这可能算是一个有点太文艺的想法了。
And then we realized, let's get the cast to do this.
然后我们意识到，让演员来做这个吧。
But if I remember, currently, Josh, I think we did the pilot, right?
但如果我没记错的话，乔什，我觉得我们拍了试播集，对吧？
We did a little photo shoot.
我们拍了一组小照片。
We did a photo shoot right away.
我们马上就拍了一组照片。
Like in the booth, kind of like Candid's.
就像在照相亭里那样，有点像抓拍。
I remember, did Jason hold the camera?
我记得，是杰森拿着相机吗？
Was it like a selfie?
就像是自拍吗？
I think sometimes you guys were selfieing and I think sometimes literally Pam Fryman, our director, I think was like shooting it on at what at that time was like a crappy like disposable camera.
我觉得有时候是你们在自拍，而且我觉得有时候确实是我们的导演帕姆·弗莱曼，当时正用一台现在看来很烂的一次性相机在拍。
These were on phone packs, right?
这些都是用这种傻瓜相机拍的，对吧？
And you see that Lily, it looks, and it dates the show so much, but you see in titles that Lily is holding that old disposable camera.
你看莉莉手里拿的，它让这部剧充满了时代的印记，但你在片头里能看到莉莉拿着那个老式的一次性相机。
That's literally what they're still getting.
这确实就是他们当时用的那种。
So they're placed on tables at weddings, you know, there's still in use.
所以它们被放在婚礼的桌子上，你知道的，现在还在使用。
Ironically.
具有讽刺意味的是。
Where the like color scheme come up with like that kind of seepia, so I really like the kind of rods and yellows and.
那种复古的色调是怎么来的，比如那种棕褐色、红色和黄色的感觉？
We said we wanted to feel like memories, like these sort of old tinge sort of like seepia tone, sort of like just this feeling of these exist as memories in someone's mind.
我们说过，我们希望它感觉像回忆，就像这种带点老旧色彩、有点棕褐色的基调，就像是在某人脑海中作为回忆存在的那种感觉。
Yeah.
是啊。
And when did you guys hit on using the solid song or the end of Hey Beautiful?
你们是什么时候决定用The Sol Seeds的歌或者《Hey Beautiful》的结尾的？
I think we, for a minute, we wanted to use, I've never said this either, I think, we wanted to use a replacement song.
我想有一会儿，我们想用，我也从来没说过这个，我想，我们想用替换乐队（The Replacements）的歌。
The band replacement, Carter and I are huge fans replacements card turned me into a replacement span.
The Replacements乐队，卡特和我都是The Replacements的超级粉丝，卡特让我迷上了The Replacements。
And we were talking about using, um, I think we're going to, I think we're going to use the song unsatisfied.
我们在讨论用，嗯，我想我们要用，我想我们要用《Unsatisfied》这首歌。
Like, and literally, I think we cut a version of the main titles that was pictures of total strangers set to the replacement song unsatisfied.
真的，我想我们剪辑了一个版本的片头，里面全是不认识的陌生人的照片，配上The Replacements的歌《Unsatisfied》。
It looks like it's just opening titles to an entirely different show called unsatisfied.
看起来就像是一部完全不同的电视剧的片头，剧名就叫《不满意》（Unsatisfied）。
It was utterly confusing and it was a complete fail, but it's what taught us that we needed it to be our cast.
这让人感到无比困惑，彻底搞砸了，但正是这件事教会了我们：我们需要用我们自己的演员。
And the idea of photos and memories like that, that was always the idea, but we had to do a bad like misguided version of that to get to what it became.
照片和类似回忆的想法，这个想法一直都在，但我们必须先做一个糟糕的、被误导的版本，才能最终变成后来的样子。
And isn't Barney's last name after a guitar like a replacement?
巴尼的姓氏是不是取自某个吉他手，就像The Replacements乐队里的那样？
Yeah, Barney Stinson.
是的，巴尼·斯廷森（Barney Stinson）。
Stinson, Tommy Stinson is the bass player for the replacements, and that is a shout out to the replacements.
斯廷森，汤米·斯廷森（Tommy Stinson）是The Replacements的贝斯手，这是对The Replacements的致敬。
Who again, and we really wanted to unsatisfied to be the song, and then we got the bill for what that would cost every week.
再说一次，我们真的很想把《Unsatisfied》作为主题曲，然后我们收到了每周需要支付多少版权费的账单。
And then we said, what if we put our own band song on there, And we get that money.
然后我们说，如果我们把我们自己乐队的歌放上去，然后我们拿到那笔钱呢？
And they said, what about one tenth of that money?
他们说，那十分之一的钱怎么样？
I said souls.
我说：The Solids（乐队名）。
Craig, did you need to get approval at this point?
克雷格，你当时需要获得批准吗？
Did the studio or network have to like, look at that title sequence?
制片厂或电视台必须过目并审核那个片头序列吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
That thing is like tested and game down and sent up and down the chain.
那个东西经过了测试、推敲，并在整个层级中上下传达。
It's, it's, it's the branding of the show, right?
这就是，这就是，这就是节目的品牌形象，对吧？
It's like the brand does become so iconic.
就像这个品牌真的变得如此具有标志性。
And what's amazing about it now is like, I see people online.
现在最让人惊叹的是，我看到网上的那些人。
I see people on socials like them and their friends are literally shot for shot recreating how I met your mother photos from the opening main titles and they're doing it with their own friends.
我在社交媒体上看到，他们和朋友们一帧一帧地完美还原《老爸老妈浪漫史》片头主标题里的照片，他们是用自己的朋友来拍的。
And I find that so moving and pointing like we've passed this baton onto this younger generation who are now like enacting it.
我觉得这太感人、太深刻了，就像我们把这根接力棒交给了现在正在模仿它的年轻一代。
And it's their way of saying we're making our own memories now I think which is a story that Josh you've told to about a fan told you said do you I realize I'm living these memories now and that's I love the idea that like young people watching the show are creating that themselves.
这也是他们表达“我们现在正在创造属于自己的回忆”的一种方式吧，乔希，你之前也讲过一个故事，有个粉丝告诉你，她说：“你知道吗？我意识到我现在正在经历这些回忆。”我特别喜欢这种想法，看节目的年轻人正在亲手创造这些。
Yeah.
是的。
So speaking of memories.
所以说到回忆。
So Josh, so at this point when week three of producing this show, obviously spread over time between the pilot and the second episode, but what was your week like, at least in this first season, how did that script first come to on what day rehearsal blocking?
那么乔希，在制作这部节目的第三周这个时候，虽然试播集和第二集之间显然隔了一段时间，但你的那一周是怎么过的？至少在第一季的时候，那个剧本是哪天出来的？什么时候排练、走位？
How did it look for you?
对你来说是什么样的？
My memory is in Craig maybe like we would get an envelope over the weekend.
我的记忆是，也许我和克雷格会在周末收到一个信封。
Yeah, like on a Sunday, I think maybe sometimes Friday, sometimes Friday, but hard copies in a in a Manila envelope kind of like waiting at your door.
对，就像在周日，我想有时也可能是周五，但都是纸质版，装在马尼拉纸信封里，放在你家门口那种。
Yeah, and you'd read and that was the table script.
对，然后你就会读，那就是围读剧本。
That was the script we were going to read Monday at like 10 a.m.
那是我们周一上午10点左右要读的剧本。
Correct.
没错。
So the actors would come in at 10 a.m.
所以演员们会在周一上午10点
on Monday.
来到现场。
We'd sit around a table.
我们围坐在一张桌子旁。
There was a great spread of food.
那里有非常丰盛的食物。
All the writers were where their producers, the department heads would come to that.
所有的编剧、制片人、各部门负责人都会来参加。
Yeah.
对。
And we'd like to get around this.
我们会聚在一起……
Yeah, we, the studio execs network execs, we'd sit around and it was, it was not a high pressure.
对，我们，还有工作室高管、电视台高管，我们围坐在一起，而且那并没有太大的压力。
I never felt beyond maybe the pilot table read.
除了试播集的围读桌上可能有一点，我从来没觉得压力有多大。
That was always like the chillest low pressure kind of thing.
那一直是一种最轻松、压力最小的事情。
So we'd read the script, Pam would read the stage directions and you and Carter would flank Pam, I remember.
所以我们会读剧本，帕姆会读舞台说明，我记得你和卡特分别坐在帕姆的两侧。
Yeah.
是的。
And by the way, just to say counterpoint, I was wildly nervous for all 200 native tables.
顺便说一下，作为反衬，我其实对所有那200场母语剧本围读都感到极度紧张。
You were.
你是这样的。
Okay.
好吧。
Well, miserably anxious.
嗯，痛苦地焦虑。
I shocked that you weren't.
我很震惊你居然不紧张。
But think about writer brand.
但想想编剧的品牌。
Think about writer brand versus actor brand.
想想编剧的品牌和演员的品牌。
But they will read all about the script.
但他们会去了解剧本的一切。
I mean, it's about performance, but we weren't.
我的意思是，虽然这关乎表演，但我们并不是那样。
People were listening to the script.
人们是在听剧本。
They weren't even watching us read it.
他们甚至没有看我们朗读。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
They were listening to it in the air.
他们只是在空中收听它。
It was like a radio play.
就像广播剧一样。
To me, I'd always felt like a high stakes courtroom trial for the script.
对我而言，我一直觉得这就像是一场对剧本的高风险法庭审判。
And like the script, the script might be like executed at the end of it.
而且感觉剧本，剧本到最后可能会被“处决”。
I always fought a pit in my stomach.
我的胃里总有一种翻江倒海的感觉。
It was great when it went great, but- What's the thing where writers will write down if they think a joke is good, but do they just write P for performance?
顺利的时候当然很好，但是——编剧觉得一个笑话不错时会写下来，他们是写个“P”代表表演吗？
The P means punch it.
“P”的意思是润色（Punch it）。
P means punch in writer's opinion.
在编剧的意见里，“P”代表进行润色。
Oh, okay.
哦，好吧。
So what are the things that you're struggling with?
那么你目前在纠结什么呢？
Were you say, that was the actress fault, not mine.
你会不会说，那是演员的错，不是我的。
I don't know that there's a universal code for that.
我不知道针对那种情况有没有什么行业通行的暗号。
I heard there was something where you write in like, bad line reading, like, good joke.
我听说过有什么写在剧本上的，比如台词念得烂，但笑话本身不错。
Or something like, we should say that- That's, that's also writers being fucking dicks, right?
或者类似的话，我们得说——这也是编剧们真他妈混蛋的表现，对吧？
It was definitely the actor's fall.
那绝对是演员的错。
Like, I don't know about that.
我觉得吧，这事儿说不准。
And some writers do that.
有些编剧确实会这样。
So we would read, it would be done by 1045, no later than 11.
所以我们读本，10点45分就能结束，最迟不超过11点。
Yeah.
对。
We go home for the rest of the day.
剩下的时间我们就回家。
The actor's leave.
演员们就走了。
You can just say one thing about the table read, sorry, as someone who just sat in on some of them.
关于剧本围读，我能说一句吗，抱歉，作为一个刚刚旁听过其中几次的人。
You say it wasn't for the actor's room for the script.
你说那不是为了演员的空间，而是为了剧本。
Certainly for me who had no stake in this spot, so ever, it was a, it was such a joy to listen to the radio play version of it, because you guys maybe because the pressure was so low, you guys were so loose.
当然，对我这样一个对这个项目完全没有任何利益相关的人来说，听广播剧版的读本简直是一种巨大的享受，因为你们——也许是因为压力很小，你们当时状态非常放松。
Yeah, you guys were great.
对，你们表现得太棒了。
Having so much fun.
玩得非常开心。
And it's the one time where the show is not about the, what becomes the great direction, the great production, the great sound.
那是整部剧唯一一次无关乎精湛的导演、精湛的制作、精湛的音效的时刻。
It's just about the five of you talking to each other.
那纯粹就是你们五个人在互相聊天。
Yeah.
对。
And it was hysterical.
而且超级搞笑。
It was always, it was great.
一直都这样，太棒了。
It was great vibes.
氛围好极了。
I was anxious because I'm crazy and I'm a writer and I'm neurotic about the writing being good enough that the vibes were great in the room.
我当时很焦虑，因为我有病，我是一个编剧，而且我对剧本够不够好有着神经质般的执着，不过现场的氛围确实很棒。
I've never been in a better table reads than how I'm in the 20th table.
我从来没参加过比这更好的围读会，尽管这是第20季的围读。
As you guys are great at it, loose and funny, it was great.
你们在这方面真的很擅长，放松又搞笑，太棒了。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
嗨，我是亚历克斯·戈德曼，HyperFixed播客的主持人。
Each week we take listeners' problems and and try to solve them for them.
每周我们都会倾听听众的烦恼并试着帮他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如这样的问题：我30岁了，但很害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我挂倒车档时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们也解决与汽车无关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果你有什么烦恼，我们不仅会帮你解决，还会揭示导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这就是来自Radiotopia的HyperFixed播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它，或者访问HyperFixedPod.com。
And now, back's the show.
现在，回到节目中。
I always love the tapery.
我一直很喜欢剧本围读。
I always loved, you know, You grab like a little bit of melon, maybe a bagel, a little smear, and you sit down, you just be so relaxed, and especially the more you do it, you're so relaxed at the table.
我一直很喜欢，你知道的，拿一小块甜瓜，可能还有个百吉饼，抹一点奶酪酱，然后坐下来，整个人超级放松，尤其是你做得越多，你在桌子旁就越放松。
Yeah.
对。
You guys were uniquely relaxed and had fun with it in a way that's not always true, to be honest.
你们那种独特的放松和享受乐趣的状态，老实说，并不是每次都能做到的。
You guys were really good at that.
你们在这方面真的做得很棒。
Yeah.
对。
And then, well, at some point you stop feeling like you're auditioning, and you're like, I have the gig.
然后，嗯，在某个时刻你不再觉得自己像在试镜，而是会想：我已经拿到这份工作了。
It's been on the air.
节目已经播出了。
The ratings are good.
收视率很好。
I have the gig.
这份工作是我的了。
I'm really hard to recast me at this point.
到了这个时候，想换掉我可没那么容易。
Yeah.
对。
season eight.
第八季了。
Yeah.
对。
So, so then we leave, but you guys stay and rewrite the script the rest of the day, based on that.
所以，所以我们走了，但你们留下来在接下来的时间里根据那个重写剧本。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
Oh, yes, we would.
哦，是的，我们会的。
You guys would be like, great, I had breakfast.
你们会觉得，太好了，我吃过早饭了。
I'm going to go, I'm going to go workout.
我要去，我要去健身了。
I'm going to go do thing.
我要去做点事。
I'm like, all right, we're going to be able to team in the morning, tearing our hair out.
我会想，好吧，我们早上要在团队里焦头烂额了。
We would stay, Monday nights were not always super laid for the writers, but yeah, we would, we'd be there.
我们会留下来，对编剧们来说，周一晚上通常不是特别轻松，但对，我们会待在那。
We'd be there for dinner.
我们会在那里吃晚饭。
We'd be there going line by line, making it as good as we could knowing there was a run through it for the next more, the next We would get a script maybe that night, sometimes late, sometimes late, sometimes I'd wake up Tuesday morning and just see the manila and the little by my front door.
我们会逐行推敲，尽我们所能把它做到最好，因为知道第二天早上或者什么时候会进行串词排练。我们可能那天晚上会拿到剧本，有时很晚，有时很晚，有时我周二早上醒来，就会看到牛皮纸袋和文件放在我的前门旁边。
Yeah.
是的。
God bless the PAs.
上帝保佑制片助理们。
God bless the PAs driving those scripts around LA, like Christmas, Elvis leaving out your doorstep.
上帝保佑那些在洛杉矶开车送剧本的制片助理，就像过圣诞节一样，猫王被留在了你的门廊上。
Yeah.
是的。
Wasn't it also funny?
难道不也挺搞笑的吗？
I hope Jason won't mind me saying this, but sometimes Jason during the table reads would laugh so loud at something that it was clear.
我希望杰森不介意我这么说，但有时杰森在围读剧本时会为某些内容笑得很大声，以至于很明显。
It was the first time he was reading it.
那是他第一次读到它。
Oh, yes.
哦，是的。
It was very clear.
非常明显。
And it was weird because it was like, oh, that was great.
这很奇妙，因为会觉得，哦，那太棒了。
It's a real compliment to the work.
这对作品来说是真正的赞美。
I think maybe he should have read it by now.
我想他或许本该提前读过它的。
But okay, like you were like you were excited that he was laughing like that.
不过好吧，就好像你为他那样大笑感到兴奋一样。
It was clearly discovering it in the moment what his character was doing.
这显然是他在当下才发现他饰演的角色在做些什么。
And giving a great offent and giving a great like cold read, yeah.
并且给出了极棒的临场表现和极棒的盲读，对吧。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
I know he's in me.
我知道他在我心里。
He knew we could do that.
他知道我们能做到。
But yeah, that was, I guess, that was the thing.
但对，那就是，我猜，就是那么回事。
Yeah.
是的。
But it was a very generous laugh.
但那是一种非常慷慨的笑声。
You'd get the script and it would have asterisks on the, it would be a different color pages, right?
你拿到剧本时，上面会有星号，会是不同颜色的纸页，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
you get the script and how the asterisks where all the changes had been revision marks for the previous, right?
你拿到剧本，上面有星号标记着所有的修改地方，是前一次的修订标记，对吧？
So did you ever did your heart sink when you when you found one that was like just machine gun fire asterisks all the way down?
那么，当你发现其中一页密密麻麻全都是像机关枪扫射一样的星号时，你的心有没有往下沉过？
You're like, ooh, well, it was really like you guys cracked it like you solved the thing.
你会想，哦，好吧，这真的很像你们把问题给攻克了，就像你们把事情搞定了一样。
Yeah, no other times, other times there were a few episodes where I felt like you guys were really chasing it like really you had you wrote three scripts in three days.
对，有时候不会，有时候会有几个剧集，我觉得你们真的是在拼命赶进度，就像你们真的在三天里写了三个剧本一样。
Did you ever get one and you're like really no asterisks here?
你们有没有拿到过这样的剧本，心想这里真的没有星号？
You're sticking with that one.
你们就打算用这个了。
But there were also there were also you go through and you you kind of feel like, oh, maybe I blew that joke and now that joke is gone.
但也有过，也有过你翻阅时会觉得，哦，也许我把那个笑话搞砸了，现在那个笑话没了。
Like sometimes you get self conscious.
就像有时你会变得过于自我意识过剩。
Oh, wow.
哦，哇。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, like I thought I didn't blow that joke.
嗯，就像我觉得我没有把那个笑话搞砸啊。
Why is that joke gone?
为什么那个笑话没了？
That oh, well, I would say nine times out of ten.
哦，好吧，我会说十有八九。
It's just right or self hatred.
这纯粹是编剧的自我厌恶。
It's just right.
完全就是这样。
It's going the joke was no good.
因为那个笑话根本不好。
It would If you like slightly fumble the joke, but it was good, we knew it, we would leave it in.
如果你的确稍微把笑话搞砸了一点，但它本身不错，我们心知肚明，我们就会把它留在里面。
I think it was probably much more direct.
我想这可能要直接得多。
It was never too strong.
从来没有过火。
Most of the time it was an upgrade like it was really, especially so we would get the script.
大多数时候这是一种提升，真的是这样，特别是当我们拿到剧本。
You drive back to the Foxot like around, I don't know, 9 or 10, we'd start.
你开车回福克斯片场大概在，我不知道，9点或10点，我们就开始。
I think we started a little earlier on Tuesday, 9 or 13.
我想我们在周二开始得稍微早一点，9点或13点。
I think we're rehearsing until kind of lunch time run through.
我想我们一直在排练，直到午餐时分的串词排练。
Yeah, so that's just Pam and the cast and the props, they're all kicking around.
是的，所以只有帕姆、演员和道具师，他们都在四处走动。
the stage is buzzing, but you basically, we all clock down in the living room.
片场人声鼎沸，但基本上，我们都在起居室里安顿下来。
We'd read the script, we'd read the rewrite, Pam would have us read it, and then she would get us on our feet and we'd start staging it.
我们会读剧本，读重写的内容，帕姆会让我们读，然后她会让我们站起来开始走位。
Sometimes you or Carter were there for that initial one if there were like a lot of rewrites, but mostly you just let us do it, right?
有时你或卡特会在最初的那次排练中在场，如果有很多重写的话，但大部分时候你们只是放手让我们自己做，对吧？
Yeah, absolutely.
对，绝对是的。
We didn't want to be, we didn't want to be in the way over thinking the words you guys had to get it in your their bodies and start moving it through space and stuff.
我们不想成为绊脚石，我们不想过度干预你们必须把台词融入身体并开始在空间中走位等事情。
So Pam would stage the whole thing for, you know, then we'd have lunch.
所以帕姆会为整场戏进行走位，你知道的，然后我们吃午饭。
And then after lunch, the stage would, all the writers, studio executives, network executives, all the department heads, everyone would descend upon the stage and we would run through at around 1230 or 1.
午饭后，片场就会，所有的编剧、制片厂高管、电视台高管、所有的部门负责人，每个人都会涌向片场，我们会在12点半或1点左右进行串词排练。
Yeah.
是的。
And we'd run through the whole show and I remember Pam would say, all right, follow me down to the bar.
我们会把整场秀过一遍，我记得帕姆会说，好了，跟我到酒吧去。
Yeah, all the sets lined up on the stage, all the sets and then we'd we'd walk set to set and to show Had so many cuts that sometimes people were like God, there's a lot of walking in there.
是的，所有的布景都在舞台上排成一排，所有的布景，然后我们会一个布景接一个布景地走，由于节目有太多的转场，有时人们会忍不住说，天哪，里面有好多走路的戏。
All the little cuts Yeah, and sometimes can't would say we're not moving.
所有的小转场，是的，有时帕姆会说我们不挪地方了。
We're just gonna stay here pretend this is the bar We're gonna sit down.
我们就在这待着，假装这里就是酒吧，我们要坐下来。
It's just two lines We're gonna sit down for many teachers of the bar That's like a year or two to figure out that we needed to like because by the end of some of these executives But by the end of the run through some of these guys are executives were like swearing We want them to be happy cardio in our runthroughs.
这只有两句台词，我们要坐下来，为了酒吧里的许多老师……这花了一两年才弄明白我们需要这样做，因为到其中一些高管排练结束时……但到排练结束时，其中一些高管都在爆粗口了，我们希望他们在我们的排练中能有氧运动。
The picture, what we're talking about here, you have a very large stage, stage 22.
画面，我们在这里讨论的是，你有一个非常大的舞台，22号舞台。
And just imagine just what you've, everyone, listening has probably seen a set of television, but you have the hero set of the couch, but then just imagine this in the gigantic warehouse, 10, 12, 15 of these little sets, you've got the dentist office, you've got this, you've got that, you've got the small things, which have been built in a day, a couple of days, And then have to be dismantled and replaced with another set often from Wednesday to Thursday once it's shot out on Wednesday.
想象一下你们所经历的，每个人，听众可能都见过电视布景，但你拥有沙发这个核心布景，然而想象一下在这个巨大的仓库里，有10个、12个、15个这样的小布景，你有牙医诊所，你有这个，你有那个，你有那些小玩意儿，它们在一天或几天内搭建好，然后必须被拆除并替换为另一个布景，通常在周三拍完后，从周三到周四进行更换。
So it was really our crew, our production crew was unbelievable.
所以这真的很厉害，我们的剧组，我们的制作团队简直难以置信。
The only sets that were there and never got touched were the bar and the apartment.
唯一留在那里且从未被动过的布景就是酒吧和公寓。
That's it.
就是这样。
Those two were always there.
那两个一直都在。
And hilariously, like, they're right next door to each other.
好笑的是，它们紧挨着彼此。
Like they're literally like butted up against each other's own little walkway.
就像它们字面意思那样紧挨着彼此，中间只有一条小走道。
You could basically walk from one into the other.
你基本上可以从一个直接走到另一个里面。
Yeah, it's right.
对，没错。
They were right there.
它们就在那儿。
But everything else would change out.
但其他一切都会更换。
And yeah, the run through would move to these sets.
是的，串词排练会转移到这些布景中。
And sometimes the sets were only half built, but we'd be pretending we were fully built during the run through.
有时布景只搭建了一半，但我们在排练时会假装它们已经完全建好了。
And yeah, it was a lot of work.
是的，有大量的工作要做。
So we would do the run through and you'd hear what was working, you'd feel what wasn't quite working.
所以我们会进行串词排练，你会听到什么地方行得通，你会感受到什么地方还不太行。
And then you guys would huddle up with the network and studio executives, right?
然后你们会和电视台及制片厂的高管们聚在一起开小会，对吧？
And the writers, we would go home.
而编剧们，我们就会回家。
We would be home.
我们会回家。
I'd leave it one or one 30 on a Tuesday and have the rest of my day.
我在周二的1点或1点半离开，然后度过我剩下的时间。
My day was just beginning.
我的这一天才刚刚开始。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, we could be given notes by our executives and often very, very smart notes.
是的，我们可能会收到高管们给出的意见，而且通常是非常非常聪明的意见。
We really, we gave ourselves the most notes.
真的，我们给自己提了最多的意见。
You know, we went back, there was stuff we wanted to change.
你知道的，我们回去了，还有我们想要改变的东西。
Like, we'd stay late, not because it was like considered a disaster just because we were like, camera's roll tomorrow morning.
比如，我们会留得很晚，不是因为被认为是一场灾难，只是因为我们觉得，明天早上摄像机就要开机了。
We want to, let's use this time.
我们想要，让我们利用这段时间。
Let's make this as good as we can make it.
让我们把它做到我们能做到的最好。
Yeah.
是的。
And that was it.
就是这样。
But then we'd go rewrite to late at night and that script would go out for me in the morning on a Wednesday and it would get to you.
但接着我们要重写到深夜，然后那份剧本会在周三早上发给我，并送到你手上。
And the production assistance would drive it to our house, right?
然后制片助理会把它开车送到我们家，对吧？
because maybe later on the run, we finally went email attachments exist.
因为可能在节目播到中后期时，我们终于发现电子邮件附件这东西是存在的。
It's not 1925, but I remember somewhere near the end going like, maybe these poor PAs don't need to be driving.
虽然不是1925年，但我记得差不多快结束时大家都在想，也许这些可怜的制片助理们不用非得开车送。
But it was for many years of a hard copy show.
但好多年来，这都是一档纸质剧本的节目。
It was a hard hit, most of the run, most of the run.
这是硬性规定，大部分播出季都是如此。
And I think even at the end, when we said we're going to switch to emails, I think a few people, a few holdouts for like, I still want to trip into my house.
而且我觉得甚至到了最后，当我们说要改用电子邮件时，我觉得还是有几个人、有些保守的人觉得：“我还是想让人送到我家。”
I like getting the hard copy and the PAs were like, oh god damn it.
“我喜欢拿到纸质版。”而制片助理们的反应则是：“靠，真特么服了。”
So then we, you guys would rewrite all night, we'd get the new script.
所以后来，你们会通宵重写，然后我们拿到新剧本。
So Wednesday morning, sometimes before I left the house, if I had some time, I would look through, and you're just looking at the start changes, because by that point you know the script pretty well, and you're just looking for what's changed, because you're going to have to shoot it maybe that day.
所以周三早上，有时候在我出门前，如果我有时间的话，我会翻阅一下，你其实只是在看新变动的改动部分，因为到那个时候你对剧本已经相当熟悉了，你只是在找哪些地方变了，因为你可能当天就要拍这场戏。
So we'd come in Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, we blocked and shot the entire show.
所以我们周三、周四、周五来片场，排练并拍摄了整集节目。
We, a lot of people don't know this, I don't know if we talked about this, we never shot in front of a live studio audience where, you know, too many sets, where would you put the bleachers?
我们——很多人不知道这一点，我不知道我们有没有聊过这个——我们从来都不是在现场有观众的情况下拍摄的，你知道的，布景太多了，你把看台往哪搁？
There's too many damn sets.
这里的布景实在太多了。
So for three days, we would make the show Wednesday, Thursday, Friday.
所以连续三天，我们在周三、周四、周五把节目制作出来。
And also, this is another reason why it comes, if you can get one, it's a great way to raise a family because you get one week off a month.
而且这也是为什么，如果能得到这样的工作，这是一个很好的兼顾家庭的方式，因为你一个月可以休息一周。
We only do, we do three weeks on one week off, which was pretty cozy, pretty civilized compared to the hours that other.
我们只工作三周，休息一周，与其他人相比，这可以说是相当舒服、相当文明了。
the writers also worked that week, you stung up a bitch.
编剧们那一周也还在工作，你这个大混蛋。
Sorry.
抱歉。
I remember one time, I don't, it was not you, but somebody who was the summer, it was the end of the summer.
我记得有一次，我不知道——不是你，但有人在夏天，那是夏天的尾声。
When we're all coming back to start shooting, we're like, you know, mid August or late August, whenever we started back up.
当我们所有人回来开始拍摄时，大概是8月中旬或下旬，无论我们什么时候复工。
And I remember one of one of you guys, one of the actors who wasn't you asked me like, you know, what did you do?
我记得你们当中的一个人，一个演员（不是你）问我：“你都干嘛去了？”
I was in Europe.
“我在欧洲。”
I was here.
“我在这儿。”
There's what did you do all summer?
“你整个夏天都在干嘛？”
And I was like, we wrote this shit.
当时我的反应是：“我们在写这些破东西。”
That's what we did.
这就是我们干的事。
I have not seen the sun.
我根本没见着太阳。
I look pale.
我脸色苍白。
I look like sick ET at the end of the movie.
我看起来就像电影结尾那个生病的E.T.。
I don't I have not been outside during daylight, but I'm glad you enjoyed your trip.
我没有——我在白天根本没出过门，不过我很高兴你们的旅行玩得很开心。
You guys always came back looking so beautiful and tan and we're like haggard limping into the start of the marathon.
你们每次回来都看起来光鲜亮丽、晒得一身小麦色，而我们就像历经沧桑、一瘸一拐地踏上马拉松起跑线的难民。
But it was, no, it was, it was awesome.
不过，不，这真的很棒。
And we would always come in six, eight scripts ahead and we'd bust our asses during the summer.
我们总是会带着提前写好的六到八集剧本进组，我们在夏天拼了老命。
And we got a little, we got a little six week, about four weeks, six weeks in the spring off the writer's day.
而且编剧日期间，我们在春天可以放一个小小的小长假，大概四周到六周。
Yeah.
对。
We had a chance on set because sometimes Mike Shay, our first A.D.
我们在片场有机会，因为有时迈克·谢——我们的第一副导演。
who's a gem.
他是个宝藏。
Hello, Michael.
哈喽，迈克。
We love you if you're listening.
如果你在听的话，我们爱你。
But he would talk us through the schedule and he'd say, you know, if we can do some real good professional acting on Thursday, we can be out by lunch.
但他会跟我们过一遍日程表，然后他会说：“你知道的，如果我们在周四能展现出真正高水平的专业演技，我们就能在吃午饭前收工。”
I always say out by lunch.
我总是说“午饭前收工”。
Out by lunch?
午饭前收工？
No, but I start, I remember I started it a champ out by lunch and we would all just like turn into Lord of the flies.
不，但我开始——我记得我开始像个狂热分子一样喊着“午饭前收工”，然后我们所有人就变得像《蝇王》里的野孩子一样。
Out by the dangling carol.
在挂着的铃铛前收工。
OBL we called it.
我们管这叫OBL。
OBL.
OBL。
OBL。OBL。
Yeah.
对。
And you did.
而你们确实也这么做了。
And you know, it was, we did work until late, late, late.
而且你知道，我们真的是工作到很晚、很晚、很晚。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
And there was outside night shoots.
而且还有外景夜戏。
You guys had some very late nights.
你们确实熬了不少大夜。
And we shot the, we shot a lot of scenes in this TV show.
而且我们拍了，这部电视剧里我们拍了很多场戏。
And it was, it was, the Wednesday to Friday was huge for a lot of you guys.
而且，周三到周五对你们很多人来说工作量巨大。
Yeah.
对。
Most weeks.
大多数星期都是如此。
And talk a little bit about New York Street, the one thing that the other main area that is not inside stage 22.
咱们稍微聊聊纽约街吧，这是除了22号摄影棚内部之外的另一个主要区域。
It's smaller than people think New York Street on the on the what was in the Fox line.
人们对福克斯片场那条纽约街的想象其实比实际要小。
I guess it's another Disney lot is it's tiny right Josh?
我猜那是另一个迪士尼片场，对吧，乔什？
It's like a little little block a little block like with a little mini turn in it.
就像一个小小的街区，一个带点微型转弯的小街区。
It's like a little like a two Ls put together.
就像两个L形拼在一起。
Yeah and it's we milked the shit out of that thing for nine years to make it look like so many different parts of New York by the end of it.
对，为了让它在九年的时间里看起来像纽约的各个不同部分，我们把那里的价值榨得一干二净。
It's like there's no molecule we haven't shot.
感觉没有哪个角落是我们没拍过的。
But you know what?
但你知道吗？
I always like shooting on New York Street.
我一直很喜欢在纽约街拍戏。
It always I always felt like a field trip.
我总觉得就像去春游一样。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Me too.
我也是。
It did.
确实如此。
It felt special.
感觉很特别。
Like a field trip.
就像一次春游。
That's exactly right.
完全没错。
Yeah.
对。
We're getting out of school.
就像逃出了学校。
I always, they always would offer to give you a ride, but I always like walking down to New York Street.
我总是，他们总是提出要开车送你过去，但我总是喜欢步行去纽约街。
Yeah.
对。
Like it felt like a nice little just head clearing.
就觉得像是一段很好的、能清醒头脑的步行。
Yeah.
对。
And it was a nice little walk.
而且那是一段很棒的散步。
If you'd five to a minute walk to New York Street and it was right up at the front of the Fox lot.
走到纽约街只要五分钟左右，它就在福克斯片场的正前方。
And you'd be standing in this little cute, like sort of little Italy-like lock, right?
然后你就会站在这个可爱的小街区里，有点像小意大利，对吧？
It was obviously in Mulberry Street.
那显然是莫尔伯里街。
And then you'd look, this cognitive dissonance would happen, and where you'd look one direction and see New York in the other direction and see like palm trees and a blue sky and people talking about it.
然后你会产生一种认知失调，你看向一个方向是纽约，而看向另一个方向则能看到棕榈树、蓝天和正在讨论的人们。
For the flow, it was always very strange, you sometimes lost track over where you were.
因为这种场景转换，总是觉得很诡异，你有时会忘了自己身在何处。
Sometimes I felt like I was really there in New York.
有时我真的觉得自己身处纽约。
It was a great, we really made the most of that little street, my God.
真是太棒了，我们把那条小街的潜力发挥到了极致，天哪。
But there was something about New York street that made me feel like old Hollywood, like Cecil B.
但纽约街有一种魔力，让我感觉像是老派的好莱坞，就像塞西尔·B·
DeMille, like there was something so grand and fun and fake but not fake about it.
德米尔的作品一样，它有一种宏大、有趣、虚假却又真实的奇妙感觉。
Like, it was really cool.
真的非常酷。
I loved it.
我很喜欢。
It felt like PB's big adventure, like that big chase of the blood, where it was like, it gave you the Hollywood you wanted as a kid.
感觉就像《皮尔重大历险》里那样，那场盛大的外景追逐戏，它给了你小时候向往的好莱坞。
Yes.
没错。
You were going to be part of one day.
你总有一天会参与其中。
Exactly.
完全正确。
Yeah.
对。
That's also where Todd runs down the street.
这也是托德在街上狂奔的地方。
But we'll get to that later.
不过我们稍后再聊这个。
I don't remember that.
我不记得那个了。
We're going to get to that.
我们马上会聊到。
We're going to get to that later.
我们稍后会聊到这个。
That's going to talk about that.
待会儿会谈到那个。
Amazing.
太棒了。
Thank you for that.
谢谢你分享这个。
That is illuminating it.
这让人豁然开朗。
I think of how this goes.
我在思考事情是怎样发展的。
And I want to, we'll keep going back to that sort of bigger questions.
我想——我们会继续回到那种更大的问题上去。
I want to ask about the writer's room.
我想问关于编剧室的事。
I want to ask about all sorts of things.
我想问各种各样的问题。
Let's do a few question number two, I guess.
我们来谈第二个问题吧，我想。
A couple of quick ones here.
这里有几个简单的问题。
A lot of people have questions about where ideas come from.
很多人都想知道创意是从哪里来的。
And obviously there's the simple answer of, well, we're writers.
显然，最简单的回答是，呃，我们是编剧。
We think of not maybe.
我们想到的——也许不是。
We think of them.
我们想到了它们。
We come up with ideas and then we rewrite them on a piece of paper.
我们想出点子，然后把它们写在纸上。
You, however, Craig, have said many times that you took from people's lives, whether they're from the writers themselves who said, oh, this happened to me or from your friends and you told them about it or you didn't tell them about it, and we'll get to that as time goes on.
不过，克雷格，你曾多次说过，你是从人们的生活中取材的，不管是编剧自己说“哦，这发生在我身上”，还是从你的朋友那里听来，或者你告诉了他们、没告诉他们，随着时间推移我们会聊到这一点。
So there's a category of question that is, how did you come up with?
所以有一类问题是：你是怎么想出来的？
So many people want to know about the idea of picking up girls at the airport.
很多人都想知道在机场搭讪女孩这个点子。
Do you recall where this notion came from?
你还记得这个想法是怎么来的吗？
If you're implying that I did this, the answer is no, I literally think it was just a pun that we liked in the writer's room.
如果你是在暗示我做过这事，答案是没有，我 literalmente 觉得它只是我们在编剧室里觉得挺好玩的一个双关语。
I think it was just the reveal that he's going to pick up girls.
我觉得这只是一个揭秘，他要去搭讪女孩。
It just worked.
就是行得通。
It was just a great little wordplay joke and we did it.
这只是一个很棒的小文字游戏笑话，我们就把它写进去了。
There was nothing.
没什么别的。
There was no real story.
没有什么真实的故事。
Every now and again, something's just funny.
偶尔就是有些东西很好笑。
That was just funny.
那个就是好笑。
It made us laugh.
它逗笑了我们。
So we did it.
所以我们就用了。
It also feels like Barney looks at every setting in the world and thinks how do you pick up girls here?
这也让人觉得，巴尼看着世界上的每一个场景，都在想“你要怎么在这里搭讪女孩？”
And he just has a scheme for every one, and this is his airport scheme.
而且他为每种情况都有一个计划，这就是他的机场计划。
This is his airport scheme and he's apparently been doing it long enough that there's might a ton of security camera footage of him doing it.
这就是他的机场计划，而且显然他做这事已经够久了，监控摄像头里可能存着他这么干的一堆录像呢。
Yeah, and I loved, I guess the emotion, the emotion I liked behind it is just how pathetic it kind of is.
对，我喜欢——我猜那种情绪，我喜欢它背后的那种情绪，就是它其实挺可悲的。
My favorite thing about Barney and rewatching it is just like he's such a broken man.
我重看这部剧时最喜欢巴尼的一点，就是他真的是个破碎的男人。
He's like, you know what I mean?
他就像是，你知道我的意思吗？
He's just like in this episode too.
就像在这集里也是。
He's just like, go along with my idea Ted to show me that I'm important.
他就像是，泰德，顺着我的想法来吧，向我证明我很重要。
Show me that I'm special.
证明我是特别的。
I find it like so like poignant and moving in a way to watch how needy Barney is in these early episodes, like more so than I remember.
我发现看着巴尼在这些早期剧集里有多缺乏安全感，这种感觉非常凄美和感人，甚至比我记忆中还要深刻。
I haven't watched these ones in a while and just like he just wants Ted to think his idea is cool and go along with it.
我有一段时间没看这些了，他就只是想让泰德觉得他的主意很酷，然后顺着他来。
That's it.
就这么简单。
He just wants Ted's approval.
他只是想要泰德的认可。
It's I have the experience watching it where I felt like I wish Ted was a little more game And I wish Barney would be a little less excited.
我在看的时候有一种感觉，我希望泰德能更配合一点，我也希望巴尼不要那么兴奋。
Like, I know that that's where the drama comes from, but just like watching almost like me or this avatar of me, I was like, you should go along with this, this could be fun, like just like that.
我知道戏剧冲突就是这么来的，但看着这个几乎就像我、或者我的化身的家伙，我当时就想：你应该顺着他来啊，这本来可以很有趣的，就像那样。
Right.
对吧。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
Not when he's drinking my tart lemonade in the basement, you know, at that point he's over it.
不是当他在地下室喝我那酸溜溜的柠檬水的时候，你知道的，到了那个时候他已经受够了。
But yeah, I mean, I think, I think we got there a little later, I think we got there more later.
不过，对，我的意思是，我觉得我们稍微晚一点才达到那种状态，我觉得我们是更晚一些才真正找到感觉。
We got some more later.
我们后来又拍了一些。
He has fun with us too.
他也和我们玩得很开心。
is some of the best nights of his life are created by this madman and it's better to just go along with them.
他人生中最棒的一些夜晚就是这个疯子创造的，所以顺着他来会更好。
Yeah.
对。
What I was struck with was, is Barney successful at doing this?
让我感到震惊的是，巴尼做这事成功了吗？
Like that's what I, I feel like later in this series, you get the sense that he, he is, he is.
我觉得在这部剧的后期，你会有一种感觉，他——他是成功的。
He does get, he does get the ladies.
他确实能——他确实能泡到辣妹。
But in this one, I was like, oh, early on, it's possible he doesn't.
但在这一集里，我当时觉得，哦，在早期，他可能并不成功。
It's possible.
这是有可能的。
These are all just games.
这些都只是游戏。
In episode one, he's playing laser tag with preteens.
在第一集里，他在和十几岁的半大孩子玩激光枪战。
And episode two, he seems to hook up with one girl in those series of parties.
在第二集里，他似乎在那些派对里成功勾搭上了一个女孩。
In episode three, he's just back to just not really, not really scoring any with any layies.
在第三集里，他又回到了那种状态——并没有真正、并没有真正泡到任何辣妹。
He's not really doing anything that impressive.
他其实没做出什么让人印象深刻的事。
Sometimes you see him with an actual woman, but a lot of times it's just a story.
有时你会看到他和一个真正的女人在一起，但很多时候这只是个故事。
He's telling.
他在编故事。
I think it's.
我觉得是这样的。
Yeah.
对。
And I would guess that 75 to 80% of his stories are either fabricated or a kernel of truth.
我猜他75%到80%的故事要么是捏造的，要么包含着一丝真相。
You know, kernel of truth.
你知道的，一丝真相。
truth.
真相。
Colonel truth.
上校真相（Colonel truth，谐音梗）。
That's the bonus one, that's the bonus one of bonus.
那是额外收获，那是额外中的额外。
We got there.
我们做到了。
That's why you remember we initiated general knowledge.
这就是为什么你记得我们开启了常识话题。
We said we're going to get to this one and it is fucking happened.
我们说过我们要聊这个，而且它特么真的发生了。
It's that no unplanned.
这不是计划好的。
Well, that was just too.
好吧，那太巧了。
That was so lucky.
你真幸运。
You are lucky.
你一直在听。
You are listening.
我是凭直觉摸索到那里的。
I felt my way to that.
纯粹凭直觉。
Just intuitively.
知识上校（Colonel of knowledge）。
Colonel of knowledge.
真相上校。
Colonel truth.
知识上校。
Colonel of knowledge.
对。
Yeah.
这太棒了。
That's good.
当你在大自然中发现这些时，感觉真是太棒了。
When you find those in nature, it's just so good.
好吧。
Okay.
我忘了我们正在讨论下一个问题。
I forgot we're talking about the next question.
好吧，乔什，我觉得大家真的很喜欢那个审讯场景，因为有多个问题，而且我会追问。
Well, Josh, I think people really loved the interrogation scene because there were multiple questions and I'll press it.
那个场景太搞笑了。
That scene is so funny.
太棒了。
It's so good.
I'll credit Mad Candy, what, oh, Mad Candy Hatter and Hazard Hanson for questions like this.
我要感谢 Mad Candy——什么，哦，Mad Candy Hatter 和 Hazard Hanson 提出这样的问题。
How many takes it, how many takes did it take for you and Neil in the police room scene?
你和尼尔在警察局那场戏拍了多少条？
or how hard it was it for you to not break on set.
或者你在片场忍住不笑有多难。
People obviously love bloopers.
大家显然都很喜欢花絮。
They also just love hearing about the notion of bloopers.
他们同样也很喜欢听人聊起花絮的概念。
And so hard to fashion a real question around this, but it looked like you were having fun.
要围绕这个写出一个真正的问题很难，但看起来你们当时玩得很开心。
Were you breaking a lot?
你们经常笑场吗？
I think that that's a pretty strong blooper presence in episode season one bloopers.
我觉得在第一季的花絮里，笑场出现的频率相当高。
Yeah.
对啊。
Because Neil, he definitely was making me laugh with we are international just doubling tripling and quadrupling down on that.
因为尼尔，他绝对逗笑了我，那句“我们是国际化的”，他反复强调了两次、三次甚至四次。
That really made me laugh watching again.
再次看的时候，真的把我逗笑了。
I do remember in the run-throughs and even when we were shooting it, the thing about the shirt, you know, the untucked shirt and his looks to me.
我确实记得在彩排时，甚至在我们拍摄的时候，关于那件衬衫的事，你知道的，那件没扎进裤腰的衬衫，还有他看着我的眼神。
And I felt like, I felt like we were, like Laurel and Hardy or Abyn Costello.
当时我觉得，感觉我们就像劳莱与哈台，或者阿博特与科斯特洛。
Road trip movie.
公路旅行电影。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
It was just like, it felt like we were a new kind of like classic vaudeville team.
就感觉，我们成了一种新型的经典滑稽喜剧双人组。
Definitely.
确实。
Where we were just had a bit and he had his character I had my character, it was really interesting to see Ted, in the first two episodes, Ted is the driver, he's got his foot on the accelerator, and in this one, he's a reactor, Barney is the driver, and I think I was really trying to navigate how to be, if I was directing myself again, I would have been like lighten this up, it's a little too bummed, and I just I wish I had had like a little smile.
我们当时只是在演一个桥段，他有他的角色，我有我的角色。很有意思的是，在前两集里，泰德是开车的人，他踩着油门；但在这一集里，他成了个反应者，巴尼成了开车的人。我想我当时真的很努力去摸索该怎么表现，如果让我重新指导自己，我会想把它弄轻松一点，有点太沮丧了，我真希望自己当时能带点微笑。
I think it's a great look.
我觉得那个神情很棒。
We can fix it in post.
我们可以在后期制作里修改。
It's not too heavy.
不会太沉重。
You can get back in there.
你可以再回到那种状态。
I think I was too bummed out by him and I think I should just been like, you know, some of that's the writing though as you point out because we could have written that I agree with that.
我觉得我当时被他弄得太沮丧了，我想我当时应该表现得，你知道的，正如你所指出的一样，部分原因也在于剧本，因为我们完全可以把剧本写成那样，我同意这一点。
I agree with that as a writing note, too.
作为剧本意见，我也同意这一点。
Look, we could have, and I think we found that I think we're like, we found out where we went on.
听着，我们本来可以的，而且我觉得我们发现了，我觉得我们就像是，我们找到了我们当时的方向。
There's a little exaggerated in this one because you had to figure out why do they keep paying out with this guy.
这一集里稍微有点夸张，因为你必须弄清楚他们为什么一直要和这家伙厮混。
Yeah.
对啊。
Well, the last line of the narration of the episode does sort of fit to that, which is great.
嗯，这一集旁白的最后一句话确实有点符合这一点，这很棒。
And that was the question we were trying to answer.
这正是我们试图解答的问题。
And the episode was like, why do they hang out with this guy?
整集都在探讨：他们为什么和这家伙混在一起？
And that was the answer at the end of that episode.
这就是那一集结尾给出的答案。
Yeah.
对。
But I remember Chris and Phil, Chris Miller Phil Lorde, wonderful writers wrote that episode.
但我记得克里斯和菲尔——克里斯·米勒和菲尔·洛德，这两位出色的编剧写了那一集。
They would refer to it as, when they went up to script, they said, we're going to write this as a Barney cartoon.
他们每次拿到剧本时都会说，我们要把它写成一部巴尼动画片。
That was the phrase that always second man.
这就是那个一直被称为第二男主角的短语。
We're going to write a Barney cartoon.
我们要写一部巴尼动画片。
They're the men.
他们就是那些人。
The brilliant minds who brought you the Lego movies and Cloudy, the Chesapeake Bulls, they are cartoon guys.
就是带给我们《乐高大电影》和《天降美食》的才华横溢的大脑们，他们是做动画的人。
They are animation guys.
他们是动画界的人。
And they said, is it okay if we push Barney to this place of being this cartoon, Ted gets sucked into it.
他们说，如果我们把巴尼推向这种动画片式的角色，让泰德被卷入其中，这样可以吗？
And it's like he's sort of the voice of reason within.
他就像是其中的理性之声。
He's sort of the human being interacting with an animated character.
他有点像一个与动画角色互动的真人。
And they push that, they sort of, that's where we first got legendary.
他们把这一点推向极致，他们有点像，那就是我们第一次听到“传说中”（legendary）这个词的地方。
That's where we got the lactose intolerant joke.
那就是我们得到乳糖不耐症笑话的地方。
That's that script is where we got all that stuff.
那个剧本就是我们获得所有这些梗的地方。
And Barney climbing out of the suitcase that he zipped himself into on the baggage claim.
还有巴尼从行李提取处他自己拉上拉链的手提箱里爬出来。
And apparently that worked.
显然这招管用了。
Apparently that got him the girl, but is that actually the truth?
显然这帮他追到了女孩，但事实真的是这样吗？
Who knows?
谁知道呢？
I do want to know the backstory of what he said to the woman about why he was inside the city.
我真的很想知道他跟那个女人解释自己为什么在手提箱里的前因后果。
But that's the beginning of his like mastery of disguise.
但这标志着他伪装大师之路的开始。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
Yeah.
对。
And they really they ran with that.
他们真的，他们顺着这个思路发挥了。
They just make it a cartoon and it was also great how you guys be to pay off legend, wait for it.
他们只是把它当成动画片来写，而且你们如何为“传奇（legend），稍等片刻（wait for it）”做铺垫也很棒。
I don't hope you're not lactose intolerant because the next part of this phrase is dairy or whatever.
我希望你不是乳糖不耐症，因为这句话的下一部分是乳制品之类的。
I don't know if I missed go to that, right?
我不知道我是不是记错了，对吧？
But you said legendary about 12 to 15 times to set that up.
但为了做铺垫，你大概说了12到15次“传奇”这个词。
Like it was literally just, it's really saying legendary to set up that last punch.
就像字面上的那样，为了抛出最后一个包袱，一直在说“传奇”。
It really is.
确实如此。
It's all there to get to that joke.
这一切都是为了引出那个笑话。
Yeah, it's all there to get to that joke.
对，这一切都是为了引出那个笑话。
And then that became this catchphrase for Barney that sort of echoed through eternity.
然后这就成了巴尼的口头禅，在岁月中久久回响。
But it was really, yeah, you're right.
但真的，是的，你说得对。
We wrote that as setups to get to that one joke.
我们写那些就是为了给那一个笑话做铺垫。
And then it took off because I don't know if he said legendary in the first two episodes.
然后它就火了，因为我不知道他在前两集里有没有说过“传奇”。
He definitely didn't.
他绝对没说。
He definitely didn't because I feel like Chris and Phil brought that in with them by writing their Barney cartoon.
他绝对没说，因为我觉得克里斯和菲尔在创作他们的巴尼动画片时把这个带了进来。
I feel like that was very much them and that lactose intolerant joke was very much, I mean, their names are on the script obviously, but it's very also very collaborative.
我觉得这非常带有他们的风格，那个乳糖不耐症的笑话也极其具有他们的特色——当然，剧本上署了他们的名字，但这也是非常团队合作的成果。
But they really came in with a lot of that sort of like fun Barney speak.
但他们的确带来了很多那种有趣的“巴尼式语言”。
They really, they really like helped define that in the show and I'll be forever grateful to them for that.
他们真的，真的很帮忙在剧中定义了这一点，我将为此永远感激他们。
Didn't they also bring in the term mind hole?
他们不是还带来了“思维黑洞”（mind hole）这个词吗？
Yeah.
对。
I think mind hole.
我觉得是思维黑洞。
They had their own language.
他们有他们自己的语言。
Chris and Phil had their own language.
克里斯和菲尔有他们自己的语言。
There's a few lines in that episode where I'm just like only Kristen Phil, like where he's like Barney asked the guy, like, do you ever touch the Liberty Bell and the guy goes, only all the time.
那一集里有几句台词，让我觉得只有克里斯和菲尔才写得出来，比如巴尼问那个人：“你摸过自由钟吗？”那个人回答：“只有一直都在摸（only all the time）。”
That's like the phrase only all the time.
就像“只有一直都在摸”这个短语。
I'm like, that's Kristen Phil.
我就想，这就是克里斯和菲尔的风格。
I can't tell you why, only all the time.
我无法告诉你为什么，只有一直都在摸。
I love it so much.
我太喜欢了。
Can I say I know there were a lot of questions about licking Liberty Bell and we don't know.
我能说吗，我知道有很多关于舔自由钟的问题，但我们不知道。
I don't know where that came from, but I did write a tweet I think years ago.
我不知道这灵感从何而来，但我记得多年前我发过一条推文。
This is many years ago, while the show was still on, where I said, I'm genuinely curious how many security guards at the Liberty Bell have had to stop himium fans from trying to lick it or throwing them out for licking it, because there had to have been an increase at the very least in attempts from zero percent to zero percent, like a couple, they have to, right?
那是很多年前，剧还在播的时候，我在推文中说，我真的很好奇自由钟有多少保安曾不得不阻止狂热粉丝试图去舔它，或者因为舔它而把他们赶出去，因为至少尝试的次数会有所增加，从百分之零增加到百分之零，就像好几个，肯定有吧，对吧？
so curious, we should get a Liberty Bell security guard as a guest.
太好奇了，我们应该请一个自由钟保安来当嘉宾。
We invite, did you invite any fans to write us, you know, write us if they ever got.
我们邀请过，你们有没有邀请过粉丝给我们写信，你知道的，如果他们曾经……
If anyone ever licked the Liberty Bell, we want to hear from you.
如果有人真的舔过自由钟，我们想听听你们的故事。
Yeah, I feel like I've sought some tweets at some point where people claim to have actually done it.
对，我觉得我曾在某个时候看到过一些推文，有人声称自己真的做过。
Like they knew somebody that worked there and they had their, they wanted to go do the how I met your mother thing and they did it.
就像他们认识在那儿工作的人，然后他们去那里，想要做一做《老爸老妈浪漫史》里的那种事，结果他们真的照做了。
I feel like I saw a couple of people that did do it somehow.
我觉得我看到过好几个人不知怎么地真的这么干了。
I feel like, I mean, we both would have to, and so wouldn't want to ask for proof.
我觉得，我的意思是，我们两个都不得不这样做，所以才会想要索要证据。
I also think it's another, like Barney is addicted to novelty, right?
我也觉得这是另一回事，比如巴尼对新鲜事物上瘾，对吧？
Like, he's addicted to newness and weirdness and no one's ever done this before and won't we, like he's a pioneer, right?
就像，他对新鲜感、对古怪的东西上瘾，而且从来没有人这样做过，难道我们不应该——就像他是个先锋，对吧？
Like, he wants to come up with the weirdest stuff, so he can say we did this first, you know?
就像，他想搞出最古怪的玩意儿，这样他就可以说这是我们头一个做的，你知道吗？
a charming, if reckless quality of him, you know, it's very, I found it very endearing because it's like, you know, Barney, they're, Barney has some dark sides and some troubling sides, but he really just wants to be sped, thought of a special.
他身上有一种迷人但又鲁莽的特质，你知道的，非常，我发现这非常讨人喜欢，因为就像，你知道的，巴尼，他们——巴尼有一些黑暗面和令人不安的一面，但他其实只是想被视为特别的人。
He wants to be important to his friends.
他想对他的朋友们很重要。
And also the epic part of that story did not involve having sex with women.
而且那个故事里史诗般的部分并不涉及和女人发生性关系。
It involved licking the Liberty Bell.
它涉及舔自由钟。
Like this is very strange out there thing.
这是一种非常奇特出格的事情。
It's not always hooking up.
并不总是只有勾搭泡妞。
Sometimes it's just doing something that nobody else has ever done.
有时候只是去做一些从来没有人做过的事。
Yeah, I like that too.
对，我也喜欢那样。
Yeah.
对。
Well, we've answered many people, of course, wanted to point it out and enjoyed pointing out this is the birthplace of legendary.
嗯，我们已经回答了很多人，当然，大家也都很乐意指出这里是传奇诞生的地方。
So thank you for covering that and with credit, I guess, to Chris and Phil for that.
所以感谢大家的报道，我想这也要归功于克里斯和菲尔。
But finally, fans do love pointing out breaks in logic all these many years later.
但最后，这么多年过去了，粉丝们确实很喜欢指出逻辑上的漏洞。
And I filter those out because you know, you're just writing a TV show.
我把那些都过滤掉了，因为你知道，你只是在写一部电视剧。
But I enjoyed that Sarah Frazier 44 did say how was there time for a beverage service on a flight from New York City?
但我很高兴莎拉·弗雷泽44（Sarah Frazier 44）确实提到了：从纽约市起飞的航班上怎么会有时间提供饮料服务？
That's actually a great question.
这其实是个好问题。
I wasn't prepared to be annoyed by this question and I'm like, Sarah, great question.
我本来没准备好被这个问题烦到，但我想，莎拉，问得好。
That's a good one.
这是一个好问题。
They were circling for a while because they couldn't get it.
他们盘旋了一会儿，因为他们进不去。
But also, you've got to be able to see in a talk about that.
但同时，你得能看到并谈论那个。
They fly Marshall drives.
他们坐马歇尔车（Marshall drives）。
He's probably getting there before like you could drive to Philly quicker than you could fly to Philly.
他可能到得很快，就像你开车去费利（Philly）比你坐飞机去费利还要快。
It's totally true.
完全是这样。
Yeah.
对。
All right.
好吧。
Busted.
抓包了。
They blessed us on the drink service.
他们满足了我们的饮料服务。
We till we'll take the head on that one.
这个我们认栽。
And that's it folks.
好了，各位。
Thank you so much for sending in your questions there on Instagram.
非常感谢大家在Instagram上发来问题。
We're going to keep on soliciting those from you on Instagram.
我们还会在Instagram上征集大家的提问。
So if you want to send in your questions, do go there and send them to us any any final thoughts in this bonus episode of whatever the name of this is.
所以如果你想发送问题，去那里发给我们吧。对于这期不知叫什么名字的加番，大家还有什么最后想说的吗？
I don't keep names of things in my head.
我脑子里记不住东西的名字。
Sweet taste of sweet pal sweet taste of liberty.
自由的甜美滋味。
That's a great dance to liberty.
那是对自由绝佳的致敬。
Um, yeah, I don't know, it was, it was just, it was a fun one, it was, it was a fun other move.
嗯，对，我不知道，这集很有趣，是一次很有趣的不同尝试。
It was the one where we started to discover Barney a little more.
正是在这一集里，我们开始更多地了解巴尼。
I love how the first two, the first two really felt like an hour to me.
我喜欢前两集，前两集对我来说真的感觉像是一个小时。
Didn't we talk about that Josh?
我们没聊过这个吗，乔希？
Like, it really felt like they, they just belong together.
就像，它们真的感觉是一伙的。
It was like an hour long story about this guy named Ted.
就像是一个关于这个叫特德的家伙的长达一小时的故事。
And then this is the episode where it's like, also, there's this speed.
然后这一集就像是，还有，这里有这种节奏。
There's this other move in this other move of this show will be this crazy guy Barney drags people on these insane adventures.
这剧还有另一种风格，就是这个疯狂的家伙巴尼把大家拉进这些疯狂的冒险里。
Obviously we're trying to like pair up Lily and Robin and sort of show that like our ladies will hang out.
显然我们试图把莉莉和罗宾凑在一起，某种程度上展示我们的女士们也会一起玩。
They're just becoming friends.
她们正成为朋友。
Well, um, so I like that it was showing other moves also as the show, this show starts here and it keeps widening at spotlight.
嗯，所以，我喜欢它也展现了其他的风格，随着这部剧的开始，这部剧不断扩大它的聚光灯。
Yeah.
对。
You know, and you're like Carl the bartender's over here and Wendy the waitress is over here and these people, Hammond Rothers is over here like it keeps spotlighting different and it keeps expanding its universe in a really cool way and this was definitely where I think you're right, you have to explain why do they hang out with this guy, and it's because they never know where the night is going.
你知道，你会觉得酒保卡尔在这儿，女招待温迪在这儿，这些人，哈蒙·罗瑟斯（Hammond Rothers）在这儿，它不断聚焦不同的人，并以一种非常酷的方式不断扩展它的宇宙。这里绝对是——我想你是对的，你必须解释他们为什么和这家伙混在一起，因为你永远不知道今晚会去哪里。
And also, you know, Ted's insistence, like, I just want to be with the same bar, same drink, same palsy friends right below my apartment, and he's, he nudges him out of his comfort zone and it's like, we need friends like that.
还有，你知道，特德的坚持，比如，我只想去同一家酒吧，喝同一款饮料，和公寓楼下同样的老朋友在一起，而巴尼把他推出了舒适区，就像我们需要这样的朋友。
Yeah, Bernie has value, he's a good friend.
对，巴尼很有价值，他是个好朋友。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请惩罚我吧。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有罪孽都可以被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔希·拉德纳和克莱格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·韦布制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Pointe de Blue Studios, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是Pointe de Blue Studios的亚历克斯·里夫斯，美术设计由约翰·莫罗完成。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这真的对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lowly Kennedy and Elliott Connards.
我们的主题曲是乔希·拉德纳创作的《NYC》，特别感谢洛利·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳兹。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的 substack 邮件列表并获取我们的社交媒体链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目重要的组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters Unsubstack, read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasWriter.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔希·拉德纳的新闻通讯，在 CraigThomasWriter.com 阅读克莱格·托马斯出版的散文，你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》（Dead Fathers Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何为本节目筹集先天性心脏病研究资金的持续公益活动贡献力量，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”（Make a Difference）标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
本集由 Backyard Ventures 提供支持，Tink Media 提供营销服务。
but will, in fact, dance.
但事实上，它会跳舞。